Sortea 1 day dugu audaderia,
Spain discusses as 1 bat partecats
in a political community.
Bad de Laco was born Bad Gazcelania,
asinsus nr
Berean,
Besteama is kunsha,
bachuk,
visiri,
mantensen di assassinlaco.
I say we are lucky
that Spain is 1 1 political community,
1 nation that shares 1 common language,
Spanish.
Silence,
silence.
Please,
look, me too,
Listen to the stuff in this camera,
I love things from this camera
and the dynamics of this camera,
but we live in 1 country in which
for too many decades
there could not be freedom to express oneself
as every 1 wanted
we suffered 1 dictatorship
and for too many years,
in 1 land such as the Basque Country,
1 terrorist group murdered anyone who thinks differently.
I don't want anyone to stand up in their seats.
and go away,
I want everyone to debate